in several other videos we have talked
about the ideal gas law
which tells us that pressure times
volume is going to be equal to the
number of moles times the ideal gas
constant times the temperature measured
in kelvin
now in all of our studies of the ideal
gas law we assumed that the gases that
we were dealing with were ideal
and now we're going to think a little
bit about what does it mean to be ideal
and what do real gases how do they vary
from actual ideal gases
well in order for us to assume that a
gas is ideal we assume that its
volume the volume that the gas takes up
volume
of gas
is negligible
negligible
relative
to container
to
container
the other thing we assume is that the
molecules of the gas don't interact with
each other
molecules
don't
interact
now in the real world we know that all
molecules take up some volume but it
could be a reasonable assumption if
we're talking about a really huge
container and we don't have that high
density of molecules in it it's a
reasonable assumption that the volume of
the gas itself that the molecules
themselves are small in volume
collectively relative to the container
and it's reasonable in many
circumstances to assume that the
molecules don't interact maybe they
don't have strong intermolecular forces
once again because they're taking up a
small portion of the volume they might
even not get close to each other too
often and so that's why these are
reasonable assumptions and they allow us
to say that pv is equal to nrd which is
a valuable thing a valuable
approximation in most circumstances but
in the real world we do know that in
actuality the volume that each molecule
takes up some volume and that if you add
up all the molecules together they're of
course going to take up some volume and
if there's enough molecules or if the
container is small enough we know that
the volume of the gas relative to the
container won't be negligible
we also know that molecules will
interact with each other in some way
shape or form two molecules can't occupy
the same space at the same time so you
definitely have some repulsive forces
and you have you might have some even
for fairly inert molecules you might
have some temporary dipoles that get
formed some temporary attraction or some
temporary repulsion
so if you're dealing with a situation
where things are less ideal and i'm
going to make a character of it where
the molecules are taking up a
significant volume relative to the
container you can't say that the volume
of the molecules are negligible relative
to the container and we assume that they
are interacting with each other they're
definitely going to repulse each other
they can't occupy the same space at the
same time but they might attract each
other at some points or or repulse each
other at other points and so in this
situation where we can't make these
assumptions we're going to have to
modify the ideal gas law